[Música]
nasci e fui criado no itaim paulista
ainda criança meu pai foi embora e nunca
mais voltou com 13 anos comecei a pegar
trem lotado trabalhei em vários
subgrupos em piso salarial tive todo o
tipo de chefe patrão
casei com o marido a bola em 1998 em
2000 nasceu meu filho levando e lancei
meu primeiro livro a literatura mudou
minha vida
hoje tenho 14 livros publicados
organizei outros 13
fiz dois filmes em captar nenhum real
tem uma livraria um sarau sou um pai
presente promove eventos fácil acontecer
eu sou a literatura marginal
boa noite ted satisfação estar aqui com
vocês é vim contar algumas histórias dos
meus 19 anos de carreira como escritor é
a princípio eu entrei na cultura através
da literatura e também com um cinema e
tv né
eu queria contar um pouco de algumas
coisas que aconteceram nesses 19 anos
mas eu queria primeira contar uma
história pra vocês que é um divisor de
águas para mim essa história é um
divisor de águas
justamente porque separa o alessandro
buzo que era vendedor de alimento na
zona cerealista no centro de são paulo
do cara que foi trabalhar com qualquer
coisa com tanto que tivesse uma ligação
cultural e essa história se passou no
meu último emprego formal vendendo
alimentos é o meu patrão me chamou um
dia de manhã com o jornal estadão na
mesa dele
ele olhou pra mim e falou por roubos o
que está acontecendo cara tem uma meia
página do jornal estadão aqui falando
que você entre outras coisas um dos
ícones da literatura marginal que você
um monte de outras coisas e como você
trabalha aqui do meu lado na minha
frente todos os dias há mais de um ano e
eu não sabia nada disso
olhei pra ele
é e só tinha uma verdade pra falar pra
ele faleceu pedro
seu pedro hoje onde conheceu pedro é eu
evito de falar por experiências próprias
em outros empregos
eu vim falar sobre cultura no trabalho
porque no dia a dia na hora do café na
hora da água vai rolar uma conversa
paralela e acaba não agradando os
patrões
então eu evito de misturar a minha vida
artística com a minha vida profissional
ele foi muito gentil em dizer que a
partir daquele momento quando eu tivesse
alguma coisa bacana para compartilhar
podia contar com ele podia falar pra ele
então achei muito bacana da parte dele
mas voltando mais para trás da minha
história bem mais para trás como eu falo
uma poesia que meu pai foi embora e
nunca mais voltou
ele passou a não ajudar desde que foi
embora financeiramente
a minha mãe era dona de casa e virou
empregada doméstica é com isso eu com 13
anos de idade em 1985
tenho 46 anos em 1985 com 13 anos de
idade o meu emprego de futebol no centro
de são paulo na praça da sé no
escritório de contabilidade onde eu
entre idas e vindas a trabalhar bastante
tempo lá trabalhei cerca de dez anos lá
e foi na praça da sé empregado
trabalhando que eu conhecia as drogas e
morava lá no itaim paulista com droga do
lado com crime do lado e nunca me
envolvi e no centro trabalhando
empregado eu conhecia a cocaína
nunca tinha fumado baseado na minha vida
e comecei a cheirar cocaína e usei
cocaína por mais de dez anos
nesse período esses dez anos foram assim
eu considero um período
eu sabia que eu estava no caminho errado
queria trombar com o poste mas não
conseguiu desviar mas eu tinha certeza
que só poderia melhorar minha vida se eu
largasse esse vício mas eu nunca
conseguia né
o vício era sempre maior mas também
nunca deixei de trabalhar nunca fui
roubar nem fazer nada para tentar ouvir
sustentável com meu próprio trabalho o
meu próprio dinheiro e três fatores
foram predominantes para que eu deixasse
as drogas para trás
o primeiro deles foi que eu voltei a ler
eu já tinha o hábito da leitura que a
minha mãe tinha me dado quando era
criança
ela me levava gibi da turma da mônica me
levava os primeiros livros em geral do
menino maluquinho
minha mãe sempre me incentivou e meu
irmão ale
então é um amigo meu montou um segundo
itaim paulista chamada segundo tante e
aí eu passei a freqüentar esses erros
comecei a ler alguns livros que eu
comprava outros que eu pegava emprestado
lá capitães de areia de jorge amado e
tantos outros livros maravilhosa que eu
conheci lá no selo e se voltar a ler me
ajudou
outra coisa importante foi que eu
conheci o hip hop eo hip hop me tocou
falou comigo eu comecei enxergar nas
letras de rap e as coisas que eu vivia
no meu dia a dia então essa proximidade
com o hip hop primeiro como fã depois
fazendo alguns trabalhos ligados ao hip
hop também foi importante para deixar
essas drogas para trás seguisse um novo
caminho e por fim o principal foi com o
meu namorado que virou minha noiva e que
virou minha esposa depois que um dia eu
cheguei pra ela a gente ainda era noivo
cheguei para ele e falei pô eu uso
drogas eu sou viciado em cocaína e eu
queria te falar isso né não a gente casa
sem você saber ela desmorou nou começou
a chorar ficou muito emocionada e
decepcionada e não esperava
e aí naquele momento eu percebi eu
continuava noivo eu continuava usando
droga
eu decidi continuar noivo estou casado
há 20 anos as drogas ficou para trás
e como eu virei escritor morando num
bairro periférico onde não tinha
biblioteca como câmera escritor eu
pegava os três é desde os 13 anos e um
dia eu achei um panfleto tinho da
ouvidoria da cptm companhia paulista de
trens metropolitanos e o treino o rio
viveu o treinar com ela época hoje ainda
é superlotado mas naquele tempo era
horrível tinha buraco no chão tampado de
madeirite assoalho furado tampa de
madeirite quando chovia pingava pelo
ilustre a água caia dentro do trem
vendendo da chuva subiu a mais dentro do
que fora e eu quando acontecia alguma
depredação alguém se revelava e fazer
alguma coisa sempre os vândalos destroem
os três que saiu na mídia e eu não
aceitava isso porque a gente sabia o que
tinha acontecido antes da redação a se
rebelarem todo o descaso que nós
tínhamos passado
ninguém contava então resolvi escrever
um texto a minha experiência de eleitor
e um pouco de eu gostar de desde da
escola de fazer uma redação
escrevi um texto chamado ferrovia nua e
crua
na visão do usuário do que a gente
passava eu não tinha computador em casa
nunca tinha feito uma conta de e mail
porque naquele tempo né
está falando antes de lançar seu
primeiro livro está falando de 98
poucas pessoas têm computador em casa na
periferia um primo meu criou uma conta
de email e mandou o texto a ouvidoria da
cptm e não tivemos nenhuma resposta
ou ele deixou de ver a resposta também
pode ser aconteceu de ele deixar uma vez
e logo acaba de lançar o primeiro livre
o programa provocações abujamra ano e
meio quando entrevistei a gente só viu
quatro meses depois eu perdi depois que
eu voltei em abuja quando eu fui
finalmente lá e falou assim uma vez se
negou a vinha aqui não é mais ou menos
isso
enfim como a ouvidoria não deu bola meu
texto
eu peguei os jornais impressos que eu
tinha o costume de ler jornal impresso
nas bancas
peguei o endereço lado a dor de todos os
jornais folha estadão o diário diário
popular na época e mandei o meu texto
para ver se alguém fazer uma matéria
falando sobre a nossa visão dos usuários
de novo foi deixado no vácuo ninguém
respondeu
ninguém fez uma matéria aí para não
perder o texto eu decidi tirar 50 cópias
desses texto e distribuir as pessoas
pegar o trem comigo a gente pegava uma
galera todo dia na maior festa à parte
boa da condução lotada que era amor
festa festa louca se era surreal e aí
distribuindo essas pessoas que ninguém
comentou nada no dia no dia seguinte
todo mundo quer falar do texto a me
sentir representado pelo seu texto
por que ninguém nunca
o antes finalmente alguém falou à nossa
versão
e aí com o passar dos dias essas pessoas
começaram a falar por que você não
escreve um livro do treino
hoje existe uma cena se imagina pra que
lado você vai ver naquele tempo não
tinha pouquíssimas pessoas da periferia
tinha publicado
eu tinha visto uma matéria no jornal
sobre o ferry tinha acabado de lançar um
livro sobre o capão redondo e capão
pecado eu sabia que tinha um livro
cidade de deus mas não era famoso ainda
porque não tinha o filme enfim contava
se nos dedos as pessoas da periferia que
já tinha publicado
e eu tentando lançar um livro é
descobrir que a única forma de lançar
esse livro independente cei bancava
pegava o livro ainda só que eu não tinha
dinheiro não tinha nenhum dinheiro
sobrando vende alimentos já nessa época
com o filho novo com esposa casa para
cuidar não tinha nenhum dinheiro
guardado em uma reserva
e aí surge uma matéria sobre a bienal do
livro que queria falar com três pessoas
que estavam tentando publicar seu
primeiro livro uma das editoras que eu
mandei o livro tentando ser publicado
indicou o fla tem esse cara que escreveu
um livro do trem
vou eu dar uma entrevista primeira
entrevista da minha vida pra televisão
na plataforma central do brás lotado de
gente road onde gente o cara com o
microfone da globo
eu falei meu pior do que encarar vocês
aqui agora eu olhei valer
será que eu vou conseguir falar que esse
cara e desliguei não olhei mais com as
pessoas para ver se estavam gostando ou
não eu falei só o repórter a matéria foi
pular todo lugar que eu passava na ponte
e na televisão
o admiro televisão porto famosão e aí
passou um tempo no livro existe algum
sonho livro puto livro existe aí com o
tempo de 90 nem explicar mas isso um dia
eu tô lá vendendo alimento mil viajando
na idéia
meu gerente me chamou não era a mesma
empresa era antes não era os elogiados
lá na frente
sete anos depois ainda 99 2000 que
lancei meu livro
e aí o meu gerente me chamou e falou
assim que o livro até você
o livro existe o que falta pra existir
eu fui a única forma é arrumar o
dinheiro lançar o livro independente eu
não tenho esse dinheiro não tenho de
onde tirar
ele pediu uma cópia do livro entregou o
dono da empresa
eu não vou ter muita fé porque o dono da
empresa mal falava bom dia
mas enfim passar um fim de semana
prolongado toca o interfone na minha
mesa era secretária do dono da empresa
pedindo pra mim até a sala dele
a lei deu uma lei deve ter lido com
pessoal nos baseado no tempo sei lá o
que vai me mandar embora ruim
aí eu pensei nos resultados - até se dar
o trabalho né
e aí subir lá ele olhou pra mim e falou
eu li o livro fiquei orgulhoso nessa
leu meu livro polícia o livro
gostei
como eu posso te ajudar falou é preciso
de x valor não virá 500 livros
ele falou eu te dou um terço do que você
precisa
um terço de 3.000 mil reais legal mas eu
não arrumar os outros dois não quer
pegar o meu dele foi embora meio
decepcionado mas depois pensando bem
ninguém algumas editoras independentes
que já tinha falado e oferecia o real de
entrada e parcelar o restante e virar
escritor de um livro na mão
vou contar só uma história do lançamento
do meu livro
estamos falando de dezembro de 2008 em
paulista lá no 40 km do centro de são
paulo lá no fundão e eu tinha colocado
livrar o trem baseado em fatos reais
nem vou contar porque ele está no script
nem é contar mas vou falar rapidinho
o livro chama o trem baseado em fatos
reais porque eu fiz uma pesquisa no
último vagão com três nomes possíveis
pessoal do jogo o show baseado em fazer
é incrível
ganhou disparado aí eu tinha colocado a
letra de um grupo de rap famoso o grupo
rci ó tem uma música famosa chamou o
trem e eu tinha colocado a letra da
música do regional nas páginas music com
os devidos créditos é claro sem pedir
autorização
aí conheceram as primeiras entrevistas
que eu dei
rapp brasil e tal escolher o contato de
alguém drco e liguei jair seu lançamento
do livro halo é 20
é o mano é o seguinte escrever um livro
aqui mano sobre a periferia de são paulo
sobre osama leste 3 a 1 aqui é o veneno
mesma coisa da zona oeste ea mesma coisa
que se fala na música fala no livro e o
livro está na mão aí o cara friamente
falou se você está ligando pra falar que
está com livros e não está ligando para
pedir autorização
meu deus depois desse gol de abreu e não
realmente não tô mas levou então você
quer e eu desconhecido ninguém nunca
tinha ouvido falar de mim o meu dedão
falei que queria saber se alguém da
reunião no lançamento do meu livro é um
detalhe só um pequeno detalhe eu por
falta de experiência marcar o lançamento
do livro o dia 24 de dezembro de 2000
o cara falou pra mim eu vou conversar
com o pessoal hoje no ensaio do grupo e
se alguém forte aviso amanhã me liga
amanhã
liguei no dia seguinte sabendo certeza
que ia tomando dispensa né
tinha certeza alô beleza eu liguei onde
do livro fumando sandro falou que vai
o grupo era célia o sandrão de gerencia
negra ali né
sandrão era um dos dois principais
vocalistas nenhum humano só não falou
que vai só você mandar um carro buscar
ele pirituba e depois levar de volta é
eu fiz dois filmes em captar nenhum real
mas antes disso eu cheguei na televisão
como eu irei apresentador de televisão
uma produtora de vídeo que eu trabalhava
chamado de gt filmes
ela fez um projeto de um programa de
televisão onde eu era apresentador que
mostrar as coisas bacanas da periferia e
aí é quando ele mandou pra tv cultura tv
cultura falar assim
buzo vocês querem adaptar o projeto de
um programa com quatro de cinco minutos
de entrar no programa manos e minas que
vai parar agora que vai começar a ser
exibido
foi assim que eu ia apresentador de
televisão três anos depois fazendo
vamos colar periférico na tv cultura me
ligaram de novo do sptv lá atrás daquela
entrevista né você mostraria a periferia
a mesma legitimidade que mostra na tv
cultura aqui na globo
falei com certeza qual programa sptv 1ª
edição o cesar tralli central vai
assumir o programa e você vai ser um
especialista em cultura da periferia
tô dentro de três anos no sptv de 2011 a
2014 foram 147 quadros exibidos na
cultura da periferia
isso me abriu um grande público é que
até então era conhecido no meio do hip
hop no meio da periferia
o sptv me levou um grande público uma
vez eu estava no mercado na casa verde
vinha em uma senhora e assim ela era um
pouco com o cuca e aí eu não sabia se
ela estava olhando pra mim ali ou se era
um jeito de andar e quando chegava na
quebrada fala humana
estamos chegando aqui no capão redondo
promoção projeto interferência vamos
chegar até nós que tá e aí essa mulher
veio ver quando ela parou de diminuir ou
pra mim falou
é nós que tá mais errar eu queria dizer
que fiz um filme no ano de 2010 chamado
profissão e disse que tem o cantor
de protagonista um ano antes de
ele estourar com algo na orelha e
recentemente o ano passado 2.018 eu
realizei meu segundo filme como diretor
um longa metragem chamado fui gravado em
são sebastião no litoral norte de são
paulo só com moradores atuando são 33
moradores atuando
essa é um pouco da minha vida é um pouco
da minha história eu queria encerrar
também com uma poesia que é assim me
chama alessandro buzo orgulho de ser
brasileiro não sonhando de copa são
paulo metrópole minha terra meu lugar
isolado fundão dallest lugar de cabra da
peste
o item é o paulista não é o bebidos boy
e tu periferia favela tudo isso que eu
vejo olhando da minha janela lugar
melhor que lá não existe é lá que eu
escrevo meus livros é lá que cresce o
meu filho
gosto tanto do lugar que costumam me
chamar de suburbano convicto
obrigado
[Música]